bonsoir thomas pourquoi les résultats se
font-ils autant attendre pourquoi le
dépouillement est il si l'on thomas
vient de ce qu'il faut prendre en compte
tous les bulletins par correspondance et
les médias américains ont actualisé leur
chiffre ces dernières heures notamment
dans les états de pennsylvanie et de
géorgie et dans ces deux états il
affirme que désormais joe biden a
dépassé donald trump et devant d'une
très courte tête en géorgie par exemple
il affirme que le démocrate a une avance
d'à peine 1 mille voix et vous l'avez
dit on a appris il ya quelques instants
maintenant qu'il y aurait un recomptage
dans cet état de georgie temps l'écart
est serrée en ce qui concerne la
pennsylvanie joe biden serait en avance
avec 7000 voix de plus que donald trump
une bascule qui s'expliquerait donc
notamment par les bulletins par
correspondance notamment dans la ville
de philadelphie qui est
traditionnellement une ville qui votent
pour les démocrates alors donald trump
conteste le dépouillement dans cette
ville de philadelphie qu'il vient de
qualifier sur twitter comme une ville
qui je cite à une histoire pour i
concernant l'intégrité des élections
alors certains médias affirment que si
les résultats dans ces deux étapes
étaient confirmés ils pourront proclamé
la victoire de joe biden car la victoire
dans un seul de ces états lui suffirait
pour atteindre les 270 grands électeurs
et on a appris il ya quelques instants
que nancy pelosi la chef démocrate du
congrès a qualifié joe biden de
président élu
les médias un thomas qui ont décidé hier
de suspendre la retransmission en direct
de l'allocution de donald trump racontez
nous
oui c'est une conférence de presse qui
était très attendu s'agissait de la
première prise de parole publique de
donald trump depuis la nuit de
l'élection ont nui au cours de laquelle
il avait revendiqué la victoire alors on
a vu un président arrivé pour en lisant
ses notes pour poursuivre l'argumentaire
qui est le sien depuis plusieurs jours à
savoir qu'il a remporté facilement cette
élection que certains essayent de lui
voler mais très rapidement donc
plusieurs chaînes de télévision
américaines ont décidé de suspendre la
retransmission de cette allocution
présidentielle regardez par exemple ce
qu'il s'est passé sur la chaîne msnbc
hockey et nous voilà à nouveau dans la
situation inhabituelle de devoir non
seulement interrompre le président des
états unis mais aussi de corriger le
président des états unis
vous l'avez entendu si les ont décidé
d'interrompre cette retransmission c'est
pour corriger le président américain y
affirme notamment que donald trump était
en train d'avancer de fausses
accusations de fraude sans pouvoir
fournir de preuve d'autres médias ont
décidé d'interrompre le président c'est
le cas de usa today qui a également
supprimé la vidéo de toutes ces
plateformes
écoutez ce qu'en dit la rédactrice en
chef de news et tout laisse justement le
président trump sans preuves a affirmé
que l'élection présidentielle était
corrompu et frauduleuses nous avons
arrêté tôt la diffusion en direct de ces
déclarations et avons retiré la vidéo de
toutes nos plateformes
notre travail est de relayer la vérité
non des conspirations infondées
finalement parmi les grands médias
américains seuls cnn et fox news auront
diffuser l'intégralité de cette
allocution alors ces interruptions de la
part de ces chaînes de télévision
couplée au signalement récurrent des
touristes donald trump ces dernières
heures font penser aux supporters du
locataire de la maison blanche qui lie à
une forme de censure autour de leur
candidat a écouté par exemple ce qu'on
dit donald trump c'était donc hier lors
de sa prise de parole il parle des
médias des sondeurs mais aussi des
géants du numérique
oui oui nous avons remporté ses
victoires et bien d'autres malgré l'
ingérence électorale historique des
grands médias de l'argent et des géants
du web comme tout le monde l'a vue nous
avons gagné avec des chiffres
historiques et les sondeurs ont
sciemment tort ils ont sciemment tort
les sondages étaient tellement ridicule
et tout le monde le savait à l'époque
un mot pour finir sur les audiences lors
de cette soirée électorale ici aux
etats-unis il faut savoir que sur
l'ensemble des audiences de tous les
médias américains il ya une baisse de
20% par rapport à l'élection de 2016
et parmi la vingtaine de chaînes qui
était en édition spéciale ce soir là la
chaîne qui a réuni le plus d'américains
devant leur poste
c'est fox news merci beaucoup thomas
bonnin en direct de washington